and welcome to Hannity and tonight we're
going to take you inside one of the most
liberal executive mansions in America
for an exclusive interview with
California governor Gavin Newsom now no
topic was off the table no restrictions
at all whatsoever I did promise the
governor that I would give him a chance
to respond to each question without
interruption so especially in the
beginning of the interview it is less
debate oriented it's a little more uh
debate oriented as the interview goes on
and as you might imagine well Governor
Newsom and I strongly disagree on pretty
much everything but to the governor's
credit he did sit down for an entire
hour he answered most of our questions
and by the way that was something that
the president of the United States Joe
Biden is not even remotely capable of
doing so without further Ado here is
part one of my interview with
California's Democratic governor Gavin
Newsom all right so I write you just
pick out a lot of pickup I'm sure you
saw as well yeah and I'm like okay I
want to do an interview yeah and but I
don't want to do an interview I want to
make sure the audience understands up
front this is not going to be me I want
you to answer and give your views I
would say you represent probably about
half the country your views and the
other half represents mine you agree
we're kind of divided plus or minus
certainly divided yeah no question I
mean I'm not you know we're polarized
we're traumatized we clearly are in
these and we're in these Echo Chambers I
mean let's be candid shot I mean you
know my your folks are watching you and
getting a certain perspective my folks
are watching other networks getting this
suspective studies that show a lot of
Democrats watch me well including me so
I'm actually I'm here for a reason to
with the point though I think we need
more of that cross-pollination we need
more of these kind of conversations and
we need to not just you know accuse each
other uh of misleading the American
people but I think confront each other
in the context of providing
opportunities to address some of the
facts that are often omitted in terms of
the conversations and topics we choose
to pick up so what I what what I see is
I don't know how you reconcile some of
these differences now you either believe
in Secure borders and and Law and Order
and people will want to come into our
country have to do it legally I'm the
product of that right
um or there are people that want open
borders you believe in defund dismantle
no bail laws like cities like in New
York where the show originates from or
you believe Law and Order safety
security is a prerequisite
for the pursuit of happiness you want
energy Independence or you want you
don't want any any domestic energy
production I mean the how do you
reconcile well I don't I say those I I
don't see those binaries at all quite
they don't see it at all no I don't I
mean I I want border security Democrats
want border security we also want
company you don't want any walls I want
comprehensive immigration reform I want
to actually address the issue more
comprehensively just like Ronald Reagan
did in 1989 just like and with respect
Sean you promoted yourself with the gang
of eight and bipartisan legislation that
got 68 votes in the Senate only To Die
In The House That Could fundamentally
address this issue which is the issue so
I don't see that I always had as my
position build the wall first you're
against building any wall I know I have
no problem with the 650 plus miles we
have on Border walls I come from a state
with the largest I mean San Ysidro is
the largest landport in the Western
Hemisphere I don't need to be educated
on the issue of the Border or issues of
immigration policy I don't think
Medi-Cal for illegals is 2.7 billion
dollars to the state and how many
billions are we spending for
uncompensated care people end up in the
emergency can they ask you on the back
end wasting taxpayments why is it wrong
to just demand if you want to come to
this country obey our laws uh respect
our borders respect our sovereignty
apply commitment and we can expedite the
application it's the the latter part now
you're having a conversation this is
where I think the vast majority of
Americans that's why I'm here well
that's the point here to bring this
together and that was the point of the
comprehensive reform where's Congress I
mean I'll give look you can criticize
Biden all the time Biden's border crisis
I watched 24 7 surround sound anger
machine around that I get it wait a
minute in three years you get it he will
allow over seven and a half million
people illegally into this country you
have to see there's something wrong with
that no I do and I see there's something
right with what he's done post title 42
a 70 reduction taking a lot of the core
tenants that the previous administration
should use he's now been sued by the
left not just being applauded certainly
by the right that said here's what's
missing the conversation you just and
you know just suggest that we should be
having around dealing with Asylum
Seekers and backlogs and updating and
modernizing our visas and addressing a
pathway that Ronald Reagan himself
acknowledged let me ask you again those
things are missing should we have
background checks yeah shoot in the
middle of a pandemic health checks uh we
did should we have means testing so the
people that enter this country are not
going to be a financial burden on the
American people we prioritize already
with certain we prioritize with stem we
prioritize with visas already we
prioritize
education and 2.7 billion dollars of
taxpayer dollars in California to
medical and that's very illegal
immigrants only and we're spending the
money already I know everybody on the
right can't stand Sanctuary policy I
understand that Rudy Giuliani by the way
Trump's old attorney was a huge
proponent of sanctuary policy I didn't
know that I actually said it keeps you
healthier safer uh and more educated
actually made those arguments when he
was governor or rather mayor of New York
it's the cards that are dealt in the
absence of comprehensive reform I'm all
for comprehensive reform I'm for
background checks I'm for addressing
border security and all its forms and
manifestations not just walls I'm
addressing a legal pathway I'm actually
wanting to address all these issues but
I want to do it in a rational way and
not just bastardize the conversation as
exclusively about the Border okay I have
here my pile of stuff the exact federal
law that prohibits now there are two
Court decisions that you might be able
to cite one is the the Trump lawsuit
that was in the ninth circuit the other
is some morning and in one opinion that
Justice Scalia gave some years back but
for the it is unambiguous when you read
the 18 U.S code as it relates to
entering the country that you've got to
do so legally
by by
characterizing the state as sanctuary
are you thereby violating federal law
the laws that are on the books and that
our own Constitution stays very
unequivocally that in fact you should be
following the sanctuary policies have
been on the books for decades cities
Democratic cities republican-led cities
in the past Democratic states clearly
more modern uh conception around dealing
with reality the cards that are dealt
you want people that are victims of
crime to come forward and Report those
crimes that's the purpose of sanctuary
you want a kid to be educated that's
here regardless of how they got here you
want that kid educated you want to take
care of someone that's an emergency and
not have them concerned that they're
going to be deported by a nurse the
point is you deal with reality but look
I stipulate I'm happy to get rid of
those those protections by doing the
hard work of actually coming together as
a nation across our differences and
support comprehensive reform and
modernize our Asylum system and
modernize our immigration system this
issue will only get worse it's not just
a border issue seven and a half million
people under Joe Biden will illegally
enter this country in three years of his
presidency to me that's unconscionable
that's unfair to the American people
that's unfair to the States including
your state that's unfair to Border
States like Texas but here's what I want
to just pause a second and and ask you a
really serious question
um I don't think Joe Biden is mentally
physically capable of being the
president of the United States
hang on I suspect if I took your phone
and I took a look at it not that I
believe in privacy I would never do that
um I would bet on a daily basis that
there are people
urging you to run for president and
primary him am I wrong in my assumption
well my phone's been lighting up how
well he did with the UK prime minister
my phone lit up and how he's that's a
nice stock McCarthy on the desk your
phone light up the phone lights up with
Republican friends saying you know what
despite all of the rhetoric these
bipartisan bills he keeps passing on
infrastructure and the chips and science
act the bipartisan work he did on gun
legislation reform and around the debt
ceiling make me feel maybe he's done a
little bit better job than something
that wasn't my question are does your
phone light up with Gavin you need to
get in this primary he's not able to run
he's not up to the job look there's
everybody has their quiet chatter uh and
everybody's out there rooting for
America I'm rooting for our president I
have great confidence in his I don't
I think his policies are failing ah chip
sack science act do you oppose that I
will tell you on every measure from the
economy inflation borders energy uh
National Security he's missing in action
let's talk about them in order wait wait
I want to challenge the premise you said
the economy 13.1 million jobs he's
created more these opposed Cova jobs you
know that well I mean that's an
artificial number no no then let me just
let me circulate this as an as an
opportunity to engage civilly on this
okay Fair Point your president Donald
Trump lost 2.6 million jobs during his
four years we've created 13.1 million
fine you can maintain a covet frame how
about the fact that Joe Biden's created
more jobs six times more jobs than the
previous three Republican presidents are
you going to tell me that the average
family where we have two-thirds of
Americans now living paycheck to
paycheck it was 70 under Trump that was
70.
we had the lowest unemployment rate for
every demo
unemployment's record low under Joe
Biden okay we had historic low after
historic low under Donald Trump Donald
Trump I mean but he's
Trump's clock Biden in terms of the
progress and job creation you're you
look at what he's done oh you grade Joe
Biden's presidency because you're at
odds with the American people and the
Democratic I'm just I'm just dealing
with your facts I'm dealing with it what
is your grade I'm going to go back let's
talk you you brought up six you got to
answer some questions I'm answering the
ones in order what brought up the
economy on the economy let's talk about
the economy inflation stubborn around
the globe let's let's but let's talk
about inflation it's down 40 since last
summer 10 months in a row 4.9 percent he
was just with the UK prime minister it's
6.9 is that because of Biden's I think
violence economic and energy policies
directly impacted the UK's inflation no
or the fact that France is 5.5 percent
of Germany's at six years on inflation
we're moving in the right direction on
the issue of the border security
imperative 1.4 inflation it went up to a
40-year level to 40-year globally
because you've just brought it so you
were making an excuse for Trump's dismal
jobs record ready to cover it wasn't it
you won't acknowledge kovid's
relationship to inflation globally and
by the way covid let me ask immigration
impacting our influence let me stop you
all right so I would assume that's funny
here's the problem that Joe Biden has
you're arguing you're fighting you're
battling you're articulate we could sit
here for three hours probably have a
beer or two in the middle of this and
you can keep going here's the problem
your president can't have this
conversation he's not capable of it now
my question is a serious one right okay
is Joe Biden up to the job of being
president and as a little reminder take
a look at your president in the monitor
there's an awful lot of stories that are
told probably a bunch of Pocketful about
uh
um
the prime minister
I'd like to take baths of that anyway
wandering around at three in the morning
yeah Winston Churchill by the way I met
with the those guys that fly over
shortly you heard them haven't
and the cheer from each year for Muslim
athletes like Kareem al-jula
Abdul-Jabbar I know him and I zip
mispronounced his name so I'm trying to
think what was the last where was the
last place I was it's hard to keep track
um
I was I mean yeah you're right Ireland
that's where it was eight e i g h
percent he said you're too much
you're too much like that guy who led
the revolution instead of the guy who
was the Prime Minister
he said you got to be less like
a military guy they shot him but God
bless you all let's go let's go late and
lick the world let's get it done
and then you got Joe Biden is having a
hard time standing up take a look at
that one standing up take a look at that
look at that
I want you to tell me that you think he
is cognitively strong enough to lead
this country against China Russia Iran
North Korea and a new axis of Evil and
that he's the guy he cannot articulate
the economy the way you just did yeah
but I don't think he's capable I know
he's capable I see results I've seen a
master class of results the last few
years you don't see the results on the
the chips act you don't see the results
on the infrastructure you had
infrastructure week every week for 40
years we're still importing them all
from Taiwan which is about to be taken
over China we had four billion dollar
proof point just here in California with
Applied Materials bringing semiconductor
investment back here in the state of
California my point being we're going to
talk about Real Results but bipartisan
results Real Results jobs programs the
IRA I know you don't like it I mean
hundreds of billions of dollars in green
energy investment mostly in red States
you're the biggest beneficiary of the
Ira's taxes on a structure Bill gas coal
pensions and quote taxes corporations
corporations don't pay taxes they pass
the cost on the consumers that's all
they do you know that on the issue of
energy Independence I think it was your
second of the the list of items do you
think he's cognitively strong enough to
be president conversations all the time
yes and I'll tell you what you do I'm
dead serious about that I've Congress
I've talked to him when he's been
overseas I've been an Air Force One
Marine one I've been in the limo with
him I've spent time with them okay but
he never answered my question directly
how many times is your phone ping a day
people saying you need to get in this
race because they agree with me that
he's not up to the job
I see where you're going with that I'm
asking no I and I'm not answering under
any circumstances would you get in this
military no none I look I really am
proud I think he's a man of decency and
character I'm really proud of the
president I'm proud of what he's
accomplished he's strong enough to be
president that's I'm strong enough but
he just did to McCarthy he ran circles
look at the vote card I wasn't voted for
it exactly Evan got played by the
president United States I'm for results
I'm for results I don't think the amount
of the people benefit I like the plan
that would have saved 4.8 trillion all
right now so we're at a point
I think you are far more articulate far
more versed far more energetic I'm just
I have this theory that people are going
to come calling because I don't think in
your party they think he's the guy
that's my my thought I now I've got
about
well I don't want to make this an
argument I want you to explain because
my argument to you is conservative
policies work okay you know I don't care
if it's Ronald Reagan I don't care if
it's Newt gingrich's contract I don't
care if it's Donald Trump's four years
as president I believe his policies work
peace through strength work building up
our military building a wall uh
enforcing Law and Order energy
Independence which Biden gave up which
he didn't bring up which I'm happy to
directly let me show you a list of
corporate headquarters that are leaving
your state in draw well let's bring it
on I look forward to having this
conversation I'm well aware corporate
headquarters they're leaving look at San
Francisco in particular they're closing
down because they can't keep their
product in the store because they're
getting robbed I got another one for you
seasonally adjusted business
applications you always bring up Florida
I compared you to Florida I think you
have a higher population if I'm not
mistaken a significantly higher price
why are they doing better in business
formula we'll have to take a look at
that more take a look I'm happy and I'm
happy that we're looking forward how
many more of these you have let's go
about eight a month let's do bring them
all on let's have this conversation okay
let me ask this is a tough question for
you I don't think it will be well let's
find out all right so you're the first
governor in history
that has had a net migration out of the
Golden State Go West Young man yeah yeah
I lived here five years I was the
poorest guy in Santa Barbara at the time
in the early 80s
um if you look at I want you to really
look at this yeah and explain for the
years 2021 and 2022 yep why Florida is
taking in nearly
a thousand people a day and you're
losing 800 people a day you're leaving
tell me why they're leaving your state
so um we'll stop at three or you want to
do the whole no no we'll just dance 18
states 18 states had declines in
population California's with point three
percent you didn't bring up any of the
red States that had declined in
populations it's an interesting fact and
I don't see it on here an interesting
omitted fact what's that per capita more
Floridians moved to California than
California is moving to Florida that I
don't imagine is in one of your eight
slides let me take another stab at this
in 2021 California 7.8 percent of GDP
GDP growth in this country one of the
fastest growing economies anywhere on
planet Earth this state continues to be
the Temple of the American economy 25.6
percent of All American jobs came from
this state in April in the last two
fiscal years we enjoyed
177.7 billion dollars in operating
surpluses we're on our way to be the
fourth largest economy Eat Your Heart
Out Germany in the world number one in r
d Venture Capital more scientists
researchers more Nobel laureates more
patents emanating out of this state than
any other state in America with all due
respect Florida doesn't even come close
Eat Your Heart Out Texas California
continues to be the dominant economic
engine for them I promised you before
they this interview I would let you give
full answers that's a full answer thank
you okay
now I'm going to challenge it good and
the challenge is is this is the first
time in the history of the state that
you've lost population yes the first
time right now I'm going going to give
you another sheet here and this is about
income tax your state income tax is 13.3
percent of the highest number I also did
more digging the top one percent of
Californians pay 50 percent of that
total income tax bill yeah fully half
roughly that's redistribution of wealth
isn't it well it's progressive tax
policy now look at yours 13.3 what is
Florida what does that say it says zero
well it's factually untrue it's not zero
they they have zeros well the top one
percent pay uh pay look here you're
you're promoting you're is that is that
is that a lie no let's here's what
you're promoting you're promoting
regressive tax policy we don't believe
in aggressive tax policy you're
promoting one component of entire tax
system the one percent with all due
respect you and I may pay the one
percent the vast majority of people
watching don't you pay more taxes in
States like Texas from the middle class
than you do in States like California
right now hold on no no this is we have
too many American people don't know this
we have the highest tax rate for the one
percent but middle class families
actually pay less than the majority of
states in America in California the
question is who are you for so who are
you fighting for I I am for I'm just
wondering because I I have homes in in
Florida yeah and pay a lot of property
tax there double what you pay in
California I would think well except if
you add the the millionaire property tax
that you've just put in LA county that's
a transfer tax and we didn't do that for
taxes like a half a million dollars I
don't know if you can get health
insurance down so you're telling me the
loss of net population 18 states we were
numbers and this number here 13.3
percent now the every Californians not
for a decade okay but right and you
supported it for a decade the public
actually initiated okay it was supported
by the public but the point is Florida
has zero the net population growth hang
on per Florida is almost is almost a
thousand people a day and you're losing
is this connected to that no I respect
your audience too much to let them be
misled on this the audience is alive in
that rare this is a lie you're
manipulating some fundamental facts
you're omitting the fact that the vast
majority of people do not live in the
one percent you're talking about the one
percent tax one percent pays half of it
yeah I understand that but I'm talking
about the American people don't live
there and the reality is when they live
in Texas versus California middle class
pay more than they do in the state of
California Texas is higher tax in
Florida that's for sure but UV seems to
be with Ron DeSantis no it was man let's
we could talk about it the kidnapper
we'll get into that in a little bit you
know here's my point we've had a
progressive tax but I didn't establish
the 13.3 percent that was done before I
even got here I have opposed new in
increases in the top one percent tax I
oppose the Statewide wealth tax I've
never been a proflica Democrat I've
balanced budgets we make the hard
choices I'm a business guy starting
billion dollars this year this state we
dominate in Venture Capital Innovation
we're the finest system of public higher
education anywhere on planet Earth we
convey more Talent than any place on the
planet this state I mean r d what what
did what did teslaitists do they move
back into the state of California
Disney's moving their jobs back from
Florida in the state of California you
didn't acknowledge per capita more
Floridians coming back to California and
Californians going to Florida this was
anomalous 18 states saw a decline I love
this state don't count us out I've been
here in this Bastion all month I am not
but I have a list of all the state
headquarters and I'll scroll them on our
screen and you could take a look at them
these are all the corporations that have
left your state and we're creating their
corporate headquarters one after another
after another there's a lot so what I'm
pointing out any jobs are we creating
how many unicorn companies how many IPOs
three times Florida so the number of
Texas don't emit all of the facts okay
okay I'm asking you know to admit all
the facts so we have all these
corporations let me give you a list here
here's the whole list Tesla Apple Nestle
or remove their world headquarters their
business headquarters out of your state
and how many jobs they've created a
whole list and how many jobs left with
them how many jobs no but you need to
know none it was insignificant in
consequence we create four companies
every single day more millionaires I'm
scrolling these no State no one half of
America's one billion dollar valued
companies are in the state of California
this state economy has outperformed the
nation 3.1 percent in the last decade
2.1 percent Nationwide I've been hearing
this nonsense for half a century
literally half a century
recent years how many have we created
how many new IPOs how many new
opportunities how many jobs were taken
out of the state of California when
Tesla moved its headquarters you don't
know that because it was insignificant
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else